hola a todos cómo están disfrutando
les voy a hacer una pregunta si yo les
pido os pido que me presten sus tarjetas
de crédito creo que soy una persona
aparentemente confiable y las guardo y
prometo custodiar las de manera eficaz
24 horas y mañana nos encontramos otra
vez y se las devuelvo ustedes se
fijarían de esa custodia por mi parte
quien me dejaría su tarjeta de crédito
y la respuesta tan evidente y elocuente
de todos o la mayoría ha sido esa que
estoy escuchando y es no entonces porque
usted es la contraseña de su ordenador
la ponen en un post y pegado en la
pantalla o debajo del teclado o en el
cajón primero de su escritorio porque al
final les digo algo el activo digital
que ustedes usan todos los días es
bastante más real
valioso que su tarjeta de crédito
yo no sé ustedes cuánto tiempo llevan
utilizando internet pero les digo algo
durante los 8 o 10 últimos años todo lo
que ustedes han hecho en internet está
guardado han sido buenos cuántos de
ustedes no han sido curiosos en internet
o un poquito traviesos hay algo de lo
que ustedes se puedan arrepentir que han
hecho en estos últimos 10 años que sepan
que hay un rastro digital y hay muchos
sabuesos que tienen la capacidad de
olerlo y es muy importante estos
mensajes porque simplifican un poco de
qué vengo yo a hablar hoy
hoy tenemos un gran desafío que tiene
que ver con esa revolución digital de la
que todo hablamos y vengo a hablar de un
contexto primero para abordar cuál es el
problema de la ciberseguridad desde un
punto de vista posiblemente diferente a
como lo han escuchado ustedes
cuál es el acto o la situación de
partida que tenemos
hoy en día si decimos que el
ciberespacio que todos más o menos
sabemos lo que es fuera el oeste
americano podríamos decir que en el
ciberespacio somos más lentos que el
caballo del malo es decir el caballo del
malo va más rápido de nosotros y esa
amenaza crece y crece y no somos capaces
de contenerla y este es el primer
mensaje que más allá del chiste que
pueda suponer el comentario creanme para
echarse a llorar
el ciberespacio este entorno en el que
todos vosotros os pasáis minutos horas o
muchas horas como es mi caso tiene una
doble característica que lo hace
especialmente diferente al entorno
cinético tradicional que nos rodea por
un lado no tiene fronteras por lo tanto
la gobernanza del ciberespacio es muy
complicada y actualmente imposible se
concibió el ciberespacio internet como
un ente neutral donde no hubiera
influencias políticas y donde hubiera
una plena libertad pero hoy en día es
una anarquía consumada y la segunda
particularidad del ciberespacio es que
podemos ser anónimos podemos ser
anónimos y eso significa que alguien
tiene una piedra en el ciberespacio y es
probable que no sepamos quién la ha
tirado por lo tanto nos encontramos en
una situación en la que podemos tener un
problema y no sabemos quién lo ha
generado entonces tenemos una amenaza y
la amenaza que tenemos en internet es
múltiple pero hay una que posiblemente
ustedes
tengan perfectamente reconocida yo les
digo o les comparto que en el
ciberespacio de todo lo que ustedes en
internet navegan solamente un pequeño
porcentaje de ese ciberespacio es lo que
ustedes tienen accesos a través de los
navegadores habituales si el
ciberespacio fuera un un iceberg de
acuerdo si el ciberespacio fuera un
iceberg podríamos decir que apenas el 5%
del contenido de internet apenas el 5%
es lo que ustedes navegan habitualmente
pero hay hasta un 95% debajo del agua
que ustedes no ven porque nuestros
navegadores no tienen la capacidad de
ver ese 95% yo lo llamo las redes
oscuras o la cloaca de internet para
entendernos todos esa cloaca de internet
el 80 por ciento de lo que está
sumergido es fraude qué significa eso de
fraude pues muy sencillo quiero matar a
mi vecino porque no me gusta voy a
contratarlo en esta cloaca de internet y
contrato matar a mi vecino por 1500
dólares y pasan los días y vive sino no
se muere y yo he pagado los 1.500
dólares por bitcoins
todo de pago anónimo no voy a ir a la
policía a denunciarlo
tampoco verdad no han matado a mi vecino
entonces el 80% de este contenido que
está debajo del agua es fraude para
intentar engañar pero ojo el otro 20%
que es mucho más de lo que ustedes
tienen capacidad de ver hoy en día es el
mal personificado ahí está el crimen
organizado los narcotraficantes los
pedófilos los que venden armas los que
venden niños los que cometen atrocidades
que si yo las contará hoy y que vemos
con frecuencia creo que ustedes no
dormirían y ahí hay un peligro que está
descontrolado y saben por qué porque
nadie tiene capacidad de leer todo eso
se venden drogas estos son anuncios
reales de internet en el black market en
esta cloaca internet se pueden comprar
registros médicos hoy en día un registro
médico de una persona en este mercado
negro de internet se cotiza diez veces
más caro que comprar la tarjeta de
crédito de cualquiera de ustedes para
pagar con dinero ajeno pero quiero que
presten atención a esta diapositiva unos
segundos si es un sicariato a sueldo si
yo quiero matar a alguien esto es un
anuncio real que se está hoy publicando
como oferta en esta cloaca de internet
yo podría sin función de si quiero matar
a una persona pública o solamente
dañarle violarle mutilarle si tiene
guardaespaldas o no lo tiene si quiero
que tenga una muerte violenta no la
tenga pagaré una serie de determinado
cantidad económica para que ese servicio
se produzca terrorífico verdad esto no
es una broma y lamentablemente pues no
va a producir mucha gracia pero lo peor
de todo que tampoco tiene gracia es que
no estamos abordando el problema
convenientemente
por lo tanto estamos preparados para
este reto para este desafío la respuesta
es evidente y es absolutamente no
porque no voy a plantearles tres puntos
de vista diferentes primero es no por el
internet en sí el internet está
creciendo como un monstruo al que le
salen nuevas cabezas todos los días hay
regiones en el mundo donde las
conexiones de internet crecen más de un
mil por ciento
el crimen organizado crece cada vez hay
más hackers hoy en día ser hacker basta
con ver un vídeo tutorial de youtube una
semana y serás un hacker mediocre pero
vas a ser lesivo vas a hacer daño luego
lo hubieras a la cárcel pero vas a ser
lesivo hoy en día hay cada vez más
malware más virus para entendernos y los
antivirus no garantizan ni mucho menos
la seguridad apenas los antivirus los
mejores pueden suponer una eficacia del
50 por ciento de las respecto a las
amenazas que existen si hay algún
antivirus se vende como que es infalible
ni lo compren de acuerdo pero luego hay
otro gran problema en internet y es
tecnológico internet está creciendo
tanto
y hay tanta información que ustedes
están familiarizados con terminología
como mb un giga entera pero no tanto con
un nexo o un zettabyte aunque está byte
hoy en día en internet se cruza la
información en tiempo real a tantos
niveles de volúmenes de datos que
estamos llegando al estado de la técnica
al límite del estado de la técnica una
gran multinacional tecnológica que
cotiza en el nasdaq hace dos años ya
levantó la voz de alerta diciendo tengo
serios problemas para mandar vídeo bajo
demanda de de mis satélites en full hd a
todos los usuarios concurrentes que me
lo están pidiendo tenemos un límite del
estado de la técnica para leer escuchar
internet si os estoy diciendo esto
internet está creciendo una manera
monstruosa exponencial el malware los
virus también los delincuentes también y
somos ciegos a ver qué nos dice internet
también se me ponen los pelos de punta y
me dedico a esto pero esta es la
principal enfoque del problema que
tenemos el segundo enfoque es sobre
vosotros yo no sé cuántos de ustedes
conocen este servicio es un portal web
para tener una aventura es un portal
norteamericano que fue hackeado en 2015
y todos los datos fueron expuestos en
internet quién es quién cómo se llaman
sus contraseñas y veis japos que se lo
merece por sí y bueno a la hoguera bien
está bien pero hubo suicidios hubo
cientos de familias rotas y bueno cuando
se expuso esa información en internet
pues nos dimos cuenta a todos que más de
120 mil usuarios de esta aplicación
tenían la contraseña 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
entonces claro tenemos un gran problema
como sociedad yo no sé cuántos de
ustedes reconocen esta ranura maléfica
que está a la izquierda de la pantalla
cuántos de ustedes no han utilizado el
teléfono móvil para cargarlo en una
cafetería en un punto de carga eléctrica
de usb en el aeropuerto o en la
universidad
no saben la cantidad de virus que
contienen estos sistemas y que están
infectando automáticamente sus teléfonos
móviles sobre todo determinado sistema
operativo que me van a permitir me
reservé el derecho de decir
por favor no la metan en la ranura que
no deban solamente en su casa de acuerdo
en el power bank eléctrico de su
teléfono
tercer punto de vista que es el tercer
vector el tercer vector
todas las organizaciones internacionales
a nivel mundial incluso esta que para mí
merece todos los respetos el foro
económico mundial
todos los años saca un informe de las
principales amenazas para la humanidad
no para castilla-la mancha' ni para el
universo humano bien bueno pues en 2018
entre dentro de las cuatro más
importantes para romper la continuidad
social de la humanidad estaban los
ciberataques por en delante del
terrorismo ataques terroristas por
delante de la crisis del agua por
delante de la crisis de la alimentación
mundial entonces porque si los
organismos internacionales lo dicen
porque no hacemos nada porque solo
hablamos pero no actuamos como gobiernos
y como administraciones públicas en la
medida que este gran problema requiere
estos son los tres vectores que se están
aconteciendo y hacen que muy pronto
nuestra nación va a ser atacada y
desestabilizada por un ejército feroz
formado por cafeteras coches
inteligentes relojes y juguetes
infantiles
porque está internet de las cosas de
conectarlo ni siquiera a la industria
está pensando ciberseguridad todos los
juguetes que ustedes regalan a sus hijos
por navidad' que controlan con el
teléfono del trabajo uil mírate mono de
acuerdo es sub súper ja que hables súper
inseguros no hay un requerimiento al
estándar de la industria para que sea
seguro lo conectamos todo pero aquí hay
un ingrediente mucho más peligroso que
se llama inteligencia artificial
casi todos estáis seguros conocedores de
esta gran película de hace varias
décadas terminator y con su maravillosa
skynet esta red inteligente que toma el
control de la humanidad y aniquila el
ser humano esto hace tres décadas podría
parecer que es un chiste de ciencia
ficción y hoy afortunadamente lo es pero
estamos mucho más cerca
les cuento dos ejemplos para que se os
vuelvan a poner los pelos de punta hace
muy pocos meses una gran multinacional
tuvo que desenchufar literalmente dos
ordenadores que tenían un experimento de
investigación y desarrollo en
inteligencia artificial que habían
inventado un propio idioma para
comunicarse que el ser humano no
entendía
yo según lo digo y lo digo mucho se me
erizan los pelos pero vamos a poner un
poco más artístico hace muy pocos meses
una máquina de inteligencia artificial
supo aprender de manera autónoma todo el
estilo y el histórico de un gran pintor
rembrandt y hoy en día esta máquina es
capaz de pintar rembrandt's sin que los
expertos más importantes del mundo sepan
diferenciar si es original o no
si no controlamos esto tenemos un gran
problema y skynet se hará realidad
y sabéis qué opinan los
ciberdelincuentes y los malos en
internet de esta transformación digital
y la industria 4.0 sí sí este término
más maquiavélico y diabólico de la
industria 4.0 de que cuando salgo de
casa he comprado un coche
automáticamente el blog change the big
data del smartphone track hace que paga
automáticamente el banco no supervisó
nada y todo se hace solo y el que la
tecnología toma control absoluto de todo
lo que hoy en día pasa en el mundo saben
lo que están pensando los
ciberdelincuentes sobre esto se están
partiendo de risa
se están frotando las manos están
deseando que lo conectemos todos porque
no se está pensando desde un punto de
vista de la ciberseguridad
podemos hacer algo por dios y que sí
bueno
se puede hacer algo sí pero con dos
perros se requieren decisiones valientes
y urgentes
y no todo el mundo tiene esa capacidad
de visión y lamentablemente no se está
produciendo esa visión que se puede
hacer hay dos vectores de actuación hay
dos maneras en las que se puede actuar a
nivel de los gobiernos mucha más
prioridad a esto menos hablar y más
actuar no hay presupuestos ni para
investigación y desarrollo para
desarrollar una mejor tecnología que
tenga capacidad de escuchar simplemente
internet
más cooperación internacional
que nada ningún delito quede impune
porque se ha producido en un país donde
no me llevo bien con él
más requisitos recibo de seguridad para
la industria la industria debería tener
prohibido vender televisiones
inteligentes si yo lo hackeo en una
semana o en dos días o en dos horas
prohibido vender juguetes que se
conectan a internet para controlar la
vida de nuestro hijo y que cualquier
hacker con insisto dos sesiones de
youtube y videotutoriales jaque a
nuestra casa
más gobernanza
aunque manteniendo esa neutralidad
internet no puede ser una anarquía
tenemos que regular la inteligencia
artificial yo no sé si llamarlo código
deontológico como se ha hecho en otras
disciplinas de la ciencia en otros
ámbitos pero la inteligencia artificial
no puede llegar a generar una autonomía
que doblegue o trasgreda la integridad y
la libertad de los ciudadanos una serie
de cuestiones que parecen evidentes
estoy convencido que ustedes lo leen y
me escuchan y estaban diciendo pues
claro tiene razón pues no se están
tomando las medidas oportunas y tenemos
un serio problema que afecta y puede
afectar a la cndh a la humanidad de
manera medular y no lo digo yo lo dice
el foro económico mundial en su último
informe y que podemos hacer nosotros
como ciudadanos contraseñas seguras
punto número uno cambian las de vez en
cuando una vez o dos cada año no usen la
misma contraseña por favor para
servicios tipo facebook de aquellos
servicios que contienen realmente
vuestros principales activos y
patrimonio y quieren conservar como su
banco
no cargue en el teléfono móvil de
acuerdo en puntos estaciones con el usb
recuerden lo de la ranura y su casa bien
no usen wifi abiertas o con un código
que todo el mundo tiene y si la tienen
que usar no hagan nada sensible sobre
ello y si no a sensores sé que hay un
montón de chicos jóvenes o no tan
jóvenes que les van a enseñar cómo
montar una cosa que se llama una red
privada virtual que es cifrar un poco la
comunicación que uno tiene de su
dispositivo aunque esté utilizando una
wifi abierta y pública no se descarguen
apps en sitios que no son oficiales si
ustedes tienen android pues se utilizan
el play the store sólo el proyector si
tienen mac apple perdón iphone utilicen
solamente el apple store o el que
corresponda no se descarguen nunca una
app de un sitio que no es oficial y no
abran correos sospechosos y los correos
sospechosos se ven claramente si una
linda señorita rusia es preciosa le
escribe porque quiere ser su amigo
sospeche sospecho un poco
sospecho un poco a lo mejor usted no es
tan guapo como se cree de acuerdo
entonces tengan cuidado con los correos
porque el ataque por phishing es uno de
los más comunes estas dos grandes ideas
son las ideas de las cosas que podemos
hacer si hacemos esto y solo esto
tendremos alguna oportunidad y
posibilidad para que si entonces podamos
intentar [ __ ] el ritmo y la velocidad
del caballo del malo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]